[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à cette autre
facebook live d'ici en fait je dis ici
c'est même pas ici ces espaces
autochtone en direct bonjour à nos
invités l'invité principal voyez la
chaise est vide elle arrive elle est en
chemin et sera là sous peu c'est joël
rébillard alors jaurès et la directrice
de musique nomade et avec joël on va
parler de cette plateforme en musique
continue nega mowin donc dans quelques
instants les puits joue l année un
invité qui est arrivé avant elle s'est
pointée le condo c ku 0 fifty tout c'est
bien ça use the writers of life tout est
ok ça et on va expliquer tout à l'heure
pourquoi ce nom d'artiste peu
particulier bonjour bonjour sur vos
biens oui comment on dit aux micmacs
bonjour oui oui ok oui y'a goût et oui
mais on vient de la langage famille oui
ça fait que beaucoup de mots qui sont
aussi muller alors guendouz est un un
micmac de la gaspésie vous êtes né en
gaspésie je pense que c'est au nouveau
brunswick mais non c'est du côté de la
gabégie exactement leur usure or
tellement beau dans cette région en plus
donc on va parler de vous on va parler
de votre travail on va parler aussi de
votre place sur n'a pas de forme ni
gamme wind dans quelques instants
d'abord bonjour charles bonjour alors
charles aujourd'hui avec vous on parle
pas du tout de musique n'en a pris une
autre orientation
de quoi sera-t-il question sera question
d'un événement vidéo c'est pour cette
semaine d'un événement qui qui parle
d'eux
d'artistes de femmes autochtones
artistes qui font une projection de
vidéos à l'habitat se passe ce soir ce
soir
donc prenez des notes ne ratez pas le
rendez vous c'est ce soir ils disent
queen bonjour oui bonjour alors illich
par contre avec vous on va parler de
musique on va parler de tous ces
artistes qui font de la musique du côté
du grand nord du nunavut entre aubry on
va parler de nouveau depuis c'est un
code très très intéressant au nunavut
les défis mais aussi des choses qui sont
en train de changer qui va faire en
sorte qu'on va savoir beaucoup plus de
musique de nouveau dans le reste du
canada
d'accord il ya déjà des artistes qui
sont incontournables qu'on connaît très
très bien il y en a plein d'autres qui
mériterait d'être connu exactement alors
coin que vous vous êtes sur la
plateforme liga maureen donc ce qu'on va
expliquer cette plateforme là elle est
toute nouvelle
elle est consacrée aux artistes
autochtones seulement des artistes qui
viennent de toutes les nations de toutes
les communautés
c'est ça ça fait cas c'est vraiment
excitant pour des artistes à tenter
parce que l'on à une place une plate
forme c'est pour nous autres c'était que
ça fait du bien à voir une sport juste
pour nous autres on est vraiment fiers
de partager nos cultures nos héritages
nos histoires qui ont fait ça avec la
musique beaucoup se fait ça donne une
place le monde peut trouver toutes les
artistes qui veut chercher par nation ou
par comme unité est ce qu'on vous a
demandé de faire partie de la plateforme
mais comment ça se passe comment mais
c'est la musique nomade
oui fait ils maquillent ont mis ça en
place moi je suis un artiste qui
travaille avec un musique nomade c'est
ce qui m'a donné l'opportunité de mettre
sur une plate-forme en premier c'est
avec un autre puis la tête les artistes
même si t'es pas avec musique normal tu
peux mettre en musique sous la forme
vous êtes un rappeur oui des rappeurs
autochtones y en a pas tant que ça
mais il y en a plusieurs on dirait il ya
un gros un système underground dans les
communautés autochtones
c'est oui c'est vrai que tu vois dans
les dts paris ou des choses de même le
monde ils vont rappeler
on a changé les chansons où ils vont
faire un petit peu de barrow grappille
aussi ça fait que ça existe depuis
longtemps
c'est juste que ça jamais vraiment être
sur la plateforme pour le jeune public
leurs attentes actuelles le rap au
tactile est quelque chose de underground
du ciné québec en tant que le rap
francophone est quelque chose qui ait
pas beaucoup présent il ya quelques
artistes qui ont réussi elle a quand
même admettre sur la sur la scène où ils
ont même aujourd'hui
mais il ya quand même beaucoup de
travail en plus être autochtone enfer
durable donc on était encore plus
underground c'est que ça doit quand même
oui c'est sûr puis c'est difficile parce
que des fois comme il faut que je suis
capable d'aller dire les choses que tu
veux dire aussi un public
oui assez pesé lourd à face ils passent
comme moi si tu m'écoutes mes chansons
je peux pas me dire qu'est ce que je
veux dire
des fois ça sale on la conseille de ton
communauté vraiment fort au chili à ce
fake dans les systèmes dessous les
résulats sion lasser c'est beaucoup
gérer toutes les choses sont gérées par
la conseil de ben oui ça fait la risée
wyss la réserve se fait que tu peux te
mettre les pieds dans une grosse star
oui oui des fois ça fait cas c'est
difficile de mettre ces choses-là en a
vendu tout le monde alors parlons-en
justement de vos textes de ce que vous
écrivez kwanten c'est vrai que c'est pas
facile c'est pas facile à prendre pour
un non autochtone mais c'est pas
toujours facile à prendre non plus comme
vous l'avez dit pour la communauté
oui c'est difficile c'est des paroles
qui touche beaucoup de des tabous on
veut des changements dans nos
communautés des fois c'est difficile à
trouver un emploi pour trouver le
changement parce que c'est le système
qui est mis en place pour nous éliminer
ce fait création il ya rien à la
médiation de la communauté de l'arrivée
c'est ça on n'a personne communauté
asteur les une résiliation
c'est une réserve oui avant avant les
années à
1850 le monde y vivaient sur la
territoire libre puis pas que tout
ensemble demain il y avait des familles
ici et puis là puis il ya des familles
qui faisait la chasse puis la page puis
tout le monde c'était une nation mais
pas dans une chic minutes et de
mindshare le système c'est pas un autre
système le système de gouvernement ça
fait que ça qu'il ya beaucoup de
problèmes dans la communauté puis lors
moi je veux garder le gouvernement
responsable pour les traités qui sont ce
qu'ils sont en place avec nos nations
les choses la main avec la loi sur les
autochtones on perd pas on peut pas
faire ce système ils nous gardent
tellement qui paie avec des petits
programmes ici puis la côte a potent
pour aller battre pour des voleurs ou
oui alors je préfère continuer on va
profiter de votre musique on va
l'écouter pendant quelques secondes ça
va donner une idée à nos spectateurs au
coeur de votre genre musical
[Musique]
c'est tiré sur lequel album celui là ça
c'est du réseau life se recroisent
ignacio les sorties ce champ sont là
dans un hippie mars et s'appelait la
robine
je parle beaucoup avec des problèmes la
nuit ratera la fin j'ai des problèmes en
nous aux violences là parce que il ya
beaucoup de tact c'est chaque communauté
change le nom tu peux changer la nation
mais c'est pas mal la même chose on vit
tout dans une système qui était bien en
place pour nous gérer puis sur ses
prochains le système change pas par
nation ces copies conformes
si ça marche pas absolument
mais vous disiez donc avec le conseil de
vente ce n'est pas toujours évident
quand vous sortez vos pièces qu'est ce
qu'ils vous disent qu'est-ce qu'ils font
assurément j'ai aucune support de mon
conseil de bande moi même dans mon unité
ça c'est sûr parce que je suis pas prêt
à dire oui même si c'est pas correct
ouais c'est pas les choses se fait à
chaque fois qu'il ya quelque chose que
je trouve pas corps et pipo qu'avec je
vais le mentionner sa septième place à
hiller stations de radio dans mon
immunité
c'est privé puis c'est une de les
conseiller qui sait la population ces
personnes arrivent y aurait jamais mes
chansons parce que j'ai en train de
décoller à chaque fois qu'ils font
quelque chose de pas correct mais c'est
pas parce que je me bats avec mon père
non monsieur je veux les protéger
absolument
je veux protéger le territoire je
reprends potager protéger l'eau toutes
ces choses là puis je suis pas d'accord
avec les signatures du conseil de bande
qui va aller donner la profession à une
compagnie minière où une compagnie de
pétrolière devenir de faire nos jours
ces taxes repas et tout d'abord pas pour
ça il ya plein de choses que je
travaille pour changer avec mais dans
mes paroles je vois touché le sujet de
due à des femmes assassinées là suicides
ces choses là et moi j'étais dans les
scouts dans la communauté quand j'étais
plus jeune nantais 14 il nous reste six
puis les autres sont tout souci d où ils
ont sûrement pas encore les hommes nous
mais les choses ne s'élèveraient chose
c'est des choses qui arrivent
puis lors d'un gros problème avec des au
pied dans les communautés il ya beaucoup
de choses il faut changer pour créer le
changement il faut qu'on parle de la
problème on ne pourrait jamais réglé ses
problèmes psy c'est tabou puis on veut
pas parler de ces problèmes
est-ce que d'en parler en le chantant
pense qu'elle est ce que c'est plus
facile mais pour moi c'est comme un
terrain public à la même temps ça fait
que la somme fait du bien de partager
ses histoires leurs pis pour dire à la
reste du monde le reste nation que c'est
qu'on raconte
on a des problèmes on peut les régler
mes heartbeats faut que ces messages que
vous passez comment sont-ils reçu
lorsque vous êtes sur scène parce que
j'imagine que vous êtes partout à
travers le québec et ailleurs au canada
oui mais oui c'est reçu par les gens qui
sont dans la salle quand ils vous
entendre raconter toutes ces histoires
là surprise d'apprendre la chanson en
chanson
ce poème c'est par rapport à une femme
qui s'appelle linda condo à vient de
montcuq minuté
assassiné dans 1988
oui puis à ces enfances si mes amis ya
pas de justice et encore cette étreinte
je parle de l danse de chant solo mais
je me mets en place de mes amis pour ses
chansons la pige expliquer ce qu'il ya
c'est difficile tu danses peau pendant
ce document non mon cher mais mes
chansons sont peu à peu sans plus y
raconte quelque chose c'est ça c'est
plus sympa plus d'inscrits ben ça c'est
sûr mais c'est ça mais il faut il faut
avoir une plateforme point discuté selon
charles vous en avez fait durant moi
j'ai fais du rap dans ma jeunesse à
l'âge de 14 ans jusqu'à 18 ans à peu
près j'étais je me suis produit nommé
comme une dame à communauté dans
plusieurs endroits quand même ça a
toujours été quand même une forme
d'expression que j'ai que j'aime et que
j'aimerai encore exploité mais c'est bon
c'est sûr avec le temps les intérêts
d'autres choses décidé prendre son temps
jean niveau du super du cinéma mais moi
j'ai trouvé ça quand j'étais plus jeune
y avait pas cessé ses plates formes là
j'aurais aimé avoir cette cette
visibilité là de pouvoir me montrer j'ai
j'ai connu j'ai eu la chance de faire un
ajustement avec samia nocilla d'une
émission que saclay la piqûre il ya
plusieurs années
ça fait quelques mois près de dix ans
d'être oblige et puis écoute c'est une
expérience c'est sûr que ça permet de se
faire connaître de se faire voir
ça a été difficile pour moi c'est un peu
ça qui meuble qui me laissait mettre ça
de côté c'est un milieu qui est quand
même assez dispendieux ça te prend un
studio ça te prend du matériel donc
s'attendre m en commun comme une grosse
préparation quand même surtout quand tu
es plus jeunes de moins en moins ça
prend beaucoup d'infrastructures pour
arriver à faire quelque chose qui est
gros comme ça c'est merci mais de quoi
vous parlez
chanson moi j'ai toujours été quelqu'un
d'engagé aussi au niveau de la
dénonciation mais pas autant que coin tu
aimes vraiment plus dans une idée un peu
plus calme un peu plus comment je
pourrais dire je parlais de mon
quotidien d'une certaine façon mais ça
n'était pas extérieur c'est vraiment
classique avec la cigarette classique
donc je n'en sais danser dans ces eaux
là dedans ça alors ku 0 52 kg ou pour
coincer oui 0,52 pour de ça c'est le
numéro de mon immunité
c'était que leurs familles à une numéro
deux du banc ça commence toujours avec
3g
oui ça c'est l'identification de ton qui
militent et puis après ça c'est ton
numéro de band hero 5 2 6 ghz gabriac
puis à 10 ty guen je pensais 051 gespeg
053 même sophie case jeunesse kabyle il
sait que c'est sa vie c'est mon numéro
un c'est écrit comme une identification
d'un mouvement
oui je me sens comme si c'est une prison
oui c'est tout la même chose
world in ça serait le gouvernement une
présence et un milieu carcéral
on sait juste l'appellation qui change
c'est ça mais est ce que c'est pour ça
est ce que c'est pour ça que vous
n'habitez plus dans votre communauté
pas du tout moi j'ai rester dans la
communauté j'étais vraiment engagée dans
mon humilité j'ai commencé la première
maison des jeunes en 1998
j'ai réouvert la maison des jeunes en
2006 15 s'affirmer il fallait que je
retourne pour leur faire jeter les
membres du conseil
c'est là que j'ai vu que garde je peux
pas changer rien dans le système oui il
faut que je sorte pour l'échangé se fait
qu'acheter toujours en gaspésie à
gabriac
mais pour les enfants des services vient
en moins en moins disponibles ce pays
des choses fait il ya rien là à part de
leurs képis la page puis ces choses là
où ils vendent en hiver c'était vraiment
difficile à faire j'ai cinq garçons puis
il ya ce qui est avec moi ces faits qui
sont il veut être actif il veut jouer la
phrase s'il veut faire plein de choses
il dit mais mes garçons c'est un comité
ou si c'était le cas il faut les
déménager plus proche à des services
comme orange et un esprit alors on va
laisser entrer notre invité dans
quelques instants
donc on va revenir sur nigam ensuite on
va en profiter d'ailleurs pour voir des
images du site vous allez voir très
fournie s'assainit gamin wind la
plateforme d' écoute donc dédié à la
découverte des musiques automne
contemporaine voilà les images bonjour
joël on va vous voir dans quelques
instants merci d'être avec nous alors
voilà la plateforme
elle est magnifique un vraiment
tellement bien construite complète en
plus je vais en profiter tout de suite
pour vous faire un compliment qui vient
d'un artiste qui n'est pas autochtone
qui s'appelle alexandre belliard
alexandre belliard est un auteur
compositeur interprète très connu au
québec
et les venues sur la page facebook des
espaces autochtone et il voulait
rencontrer un artiste au djibo est un
chanteur ou djibo ailleurs on lui a dit
mais va sur ni ga'lloween tu vas trouver
tout ce que tu veux
et en effet il a trouvé un artiste aux
jioi il al'intention éventuellement de
collaborer avec lui ou avec d'autres
artistes adorent ça commence bien mieux
pour joël joindre via bonjour vous êtes
la directrice artistique de musique
nomade
exactement musique nomade qui est né de
qui est parti de comment ça s'appelle du
wapikoni mobile et donc qui est
maintenant indépendant du wapikoni
mobile n'est ce pas oui en fait ça en
quelque sorte toujours été indépendant
mais on la petite cousine du web mobile
oui quand-même fondatrice manon barbeau
exact les rondes il ya quelques années
et ça a été construit plus sous le même
principe donc de se promener dans les
communautés d'installer des studios puis
d'enregistrer avec les jeunes les
artistes des communautés c'est que ça
s'est développé le plus souvent un
processus de professionnalisation de
collaboration artistique plutôt que de
d'éducation et documentalistes comme le
wapikoni un temps fort avec les films
donc c'est vraiment un organisme à part
entière avec ses missions et son réseau
un peu différemment à cerner de très
proches collaborateurs et d'hommes
d'accord alors donc vous allez dans les
communautés vous allez rencontrer les
artistes des aspirants artistes aussi à
vous préparer des jeunes à devenir des
artistes finalement leur donnant la
possibilité d'enregistrer et de créer
oui en quelques mots le faire peut en
fait avec les artistes professionnels et
semi professionnels c'est ce qu'on dit
donc on fait pas nécessairement la
formation musicale par exemple mais un
artiste qui que du matériel mais qui n'a
pas encore commencé à enregistrer ou qui
sait pas quoi faire avec on venir
l'épauler étape par étape
autant contre avec des artistes
professionnels aussi donc c'est vraiment
du cas par cas
on est là pour collaborer avec les gens
qui ont envie de collaborer avec nous et
d'offrir de frais les services qu'on
peut offrir selon les besoins oui hennig
emorine c'est l'idée germé depuis
longtemps oui enfin on avait on avait un
répertoire déjà de tous les artistes
qu'on rencontre et avec qui on travaille
qu'on a perduré l'automne dernier dont
il fallait réinventer un peu la
plateforme donc on ne décide de la part
amélioré donc d'ajouter la plateforme de
streaming ministre cherche le partage de
la création de playlists et tout donc on
a un peu décidé de remonter de la mettre
à jour et de créer une nouvelle
plateforme en espérant aussi en quelque
sorte d'aller chercher des artistes à
l'extérieur de notre réseau et d'en
faire un espèce d'outils tant pour les
artistes tant pour les artistes que
l'industrie par exemple le public m'a
évité faire
découvrir des artistes autochtones donc
on est vraiment plusieurs de toutes les
nations de tout les styles musicaux
donc c'était un peu ça l'idée de lancer
cet accord à perdons des artistes inuit
il y en a quelques-uns y en a pas tant
que ça pour l'instant encore sauf pour
les femmes dans notre plateforme on a
surtout parce que la plateforme on
s'entend et part avec le réseau musique
nomade surtout au québec et dans les
maritimes c'est comme s'annonce pas
c'est pas comme ça qu'on s'est
rencontrés mais surtout québec et dans
les maritimes et on a des collaborateurs
aussi un peu en ontario il de plus en
plus à ces temps mais au nord du québec
on est on n'est jamais au nord du canada
en fête et du québec on n'est jamais
vraiment aller encore oui donc quelques
artistes extérieurs à musique nomade et
on va avoir réussi la noire est par
exemple qui font du chant de gorge mais
il y en a pas tant que ça effectivement
ah oui mais justement va se tourner dès
relish parce que c'est notre experte du
nord pourtant c'est une musique qui est
de plus en plus populaires aussi on sait
il ya des artistes très connus déjà anne
dans nord riche oui sourit et les gens
que tout le monde connaît comme suzanne
aglukkaq louis bottani tagaq est aussi
ce qui est que sur le site actuellement
mais on ne vous dira tout un set musical
extrêmement riche extrêmement en santé
et que c'est pas juste la musique
traditionnelle c'est le racing métro
c'est du passé comme fox est vraiment
tout mais beaucoup de difficultés de
vraiment comme a créé le réseau musical
dans le sud du canada
et puis le problème c'est qu'il ya des
infrastructures comment alors parlé tout
à l'heure de l'internet est très mauvais
dans le nord là c'est une chose et c'est
très difficile parce que maintenant ça
se passe par ce parfum depuis itunes
mais les musiciens où il veut tuer
explique aussi qui est même pas les
studios juste d'avoir accès à un studio
où on peut enregistrer une chanson qui
est si bonne qualité pour mettre sur
itunes aux parfums c'est extrêmement
difficile jusqu'au sang oui et de choses
que le nouveau 2 s'intéresse à on a
parlé un peu comme ça fonctionne un peu
old school sait encore s'il est si on
passe ainsi dit à l'autre c'est de faire
quelque chose dans le centre
communautaire dans l'intimité mettent ça
sur youtube puis la légende en tout cas
comment se partager ça si on va voir les
gens qui faisaient ce cas peut être pas
mal
peu importe oui dans vidéo de basse
qualité mais tu vas voir les milliers de
vues ah oui parce que ça c'est comme ça
que ça serait sympa le temps de
méritoire mais aussi c'est comme les
gens se faire connaître à partir des
festivals ça peut être lié à des années
fastes euro qui est très connu et c'est
devenu aussi ça a commencé en 2005
et ça commence et comme pour les gens de
nous le veut mais avec le temps il ya
des artistes qui vient du groenland du
casque et d'autres artistes autochtones
du reste du canada et c'est devenu
vraiment une vitrine pour les artistes
comme nation inuit dans le nord il
commence de fait les at il de chansons
pour essayer de développer les artistes
émergents dont le nouveau souci et puis
une des choses le plus excitant ses
acolytes musique qui est une maison de
disques qui étaient formés au nunavut
par les jerricans
je sais pas les jerricans au chili où
ils ont commencé ça parce que ça c'est
un groupe du nunavut
oui j'entends des doutes mais il les
fait longue carrière dans les
territoires ils ont beaucoup appris
comment naviguer l'industrie comment on
peut faire les tournées dans le nord
même quand ce créneau difficile
tellement cher celui vous fendez cette
maison de dix ports et docks trois
artistes et puis maintenant comme
l'événement musical ou de nouveaux
services et en novembre mais en sorti un
disque de nous retourner je sais pas si
vous connaissez notre news c'est le
groupe périmètre iconique de nouveau les
années 80 mon attitude
il prit sa session de novembre c'est le
regret de skate
waouh et puis ils ont commencé ça et
pour faire ça ils ont enregistré la
chanson pour que ce soit de très bonne
qualité
c'est sur ce parcours c'est sur itunes
et le disque est sorti jusqu'en novembre
mais maintenant le
le gérant de la musique y est et on voit
la jeunesse sous le joug de partage ce à
partir si on est donc tout aussi et voir
ça comme une vie que aussi pour aider de
promouvoir les multitudes et qui
établirent ça comme une partie de la
culture d'aujourd'hui
alors c'est au nouveau envoyé beaucoup
de choses très très excitant qui sont
passés sauf si on collait lien avec le
sucre qui m'importe est possible de
s'adresser de nouveau y ait pas que ça
avec le reste du canada
oui alors c'est là que joël pourrait
entrer en jeu alors oui mais comment
aller chercher ces artistes là comment
vous allez faire ça mais nous on y va
vraiment par par réseau des fois c'est
les artistes qui ne contacte des fois
c'est des gens dans les communautés des
fois c'est des organismes ça peut amener
pour de bon dans ce contexte si
évidemment le je le prends note je me
dis pas que je rencontre les roses qu'on
peut faire mais oui effectivement nous
on fait aussi la promotion la
distribution fait des partenariats avec
les festivals pour assurer une
représentativité autochtone dans les
événements donc c'est évidemment c'est
du bouche à oreille but c'est de la
promotion de la visibilité comme la
plate forme aussi peut apporter qui
permet au fur et à mesure de ses des
relations etc c'est un peu ça aussi
l'idée la cdc de créer des ponts de
faire en sorte qu'il y ait une
communication plus cela devient un deal
et on le fait souvent par youtube par
les réseaux et ça se fait de plus en
plus met donc on essaie de l'emmener au
niveau un peu plus professionnel que ça
a eu un réel impact
donc dans un cas comme celui ci après
l'entrevue j'irai contacté pour effet de
créer d'élaboration alors si je parlais
de spotify dans mon titre d'article
parce que j'avais écrit un article sur
ligaments wink ans est sorti et je les
appelais nigam au wynn un spotify 100%
autochtones ou alors mettons les choses
au clair pourquoi je ne peux pas
utiliser le terme spotify non c'est pas
c'est pas qu'on peut pas utiliser je
m'énervais d'abord il appartient déjà
sifaoui
l'idée n'est pas de remplacer spotify
c'est parce que la nouvelle race husky
sont déjà sur spotify la pâte on permet
aux artistes de promouvoir leurs mines
et spotify avec tourner tous les mets
qui veulent se rapproche donc l'idée
c'est vraiment de rassembler tous les
artistes de donner cette plateforme
l'instruction pour qu'ils sont pas
distribués à ceux qui sont pas encore
dans dans les nids les plates formes de
diffusion dont il a donné ça mais aussi
de les rassembler pour d'honneur poids
pu montrer justement la diversité
lannion
une artiste qui est le nombre et la
diversité dans les cultures autochtones
aussi longue lire ensemble et ensemble
donc c'est un peu ça mais on n'entend
pas ce que j'aimerais c'est tellement
intéressant parce que justement vous
avez vous avez mentionné que que un
artiste chercher un artiste du bruit oui
justement quand qui vont avoir besoin de
musique de telle nation quelqu'un qui
doit faire la vidéo sur sur les i nous
des couennes chez p g ok mais ça va me
prendre un hymne nous un chanteur il
nous qui vont une fois de la chance on
nous met pas de la dica mais c'est pas
un peu plastique émet donc cessez donc
je vais avoir un souci de 2,2 de se
rapprocher à la culture sur lesquels est
présentée soit dans le vidéo non là
c'est un bel exemple avec alexandre
belliard donc il a maintenant il connaît
en plus sympa de forme il va pouvoir la
faire connaître à d'autres vous existez
depuis quoi un mois cinq semaines alors
déjà est ce qu'il ya un engouement déjà
ce que vous voyez le feedback là avec
cette année oui on a eu d'excellents
films bac tout le monde est très content
les organismes un peu partout aussi
l'ont contacté il ya vraiment eu ça fait
un effet boule de neige un peu pour
musique nomade aussi parce que c'est
connu au québec dans le reste du canada
- donc les gens ont commencé à réaliser
qu est ce qui se passait ils tous donc
oui mais c'est sûr que c'est une
première étape dans un essai de la
promouvoir et on veut la faire évoluer
aussi selon les feedbacks ouais mais on
a des artistes qui me contactent aussi
pour m alors j'ai volé sur la racine
donc ça fonctionne très bien tout le
monde est très content
reste à voir comment les gens vont
l'utiliser mais
je pense que ça va être utile puis
comment est on reçoit nous musique
nomade régulièrement tous les jours des
demandes de gens qui cherchent les
artistes pour collaborer pour des
projets fait qu'on fait le travail
manuellement je réalise de bons mais moi
je connais telle personne mais 7 4 me le
permet aux gens de le faire de manière
autonome et c'est ça qui justement je
fais des films de pêche avec nan mais ne
trouve jamais capable de dire ça comme
il faut un français n'est de trop
il ya françois lambert le propriétaire
j'ai parlé avec lui avant hier oui puis
garde je cherche une chanson pour mettre
son fils totalement prête à faire une
autre firme de pêche c'est qu'il ya
besoin de musique mais vous nous avez
vous avez quand même eu beaucoup de
choses sur la plateforme là pour
l'instant tout est gratuit est ce que
c'est al'avantage de l'artiste comment
il va gagner sa vie à travers ça c'est
sûr défense volontat pour l'instant les
artistes font la fondation en ville
les personnes qui pensaient mais c'est
une étape 1 en face d'eux des promotions
après prêtons évalue comment ça
fonctionne et comment les gens
utilisaient ont pris ça comme de
redevances pour les tuer mais aucun
n'est qu'après c'est gratuit pour tout
le monde on peut se créer un compte
facilement avec facebook et tous et les
artistes peuvent proposer leur musique
gratuitement mais et ont le choix aussi
de mettre une chanson de trois chansons
ou un album complet donc ces scellés
mais évidemment que ses pensées pour le
futur vous n'avez pas mis tout ce que
vous avez créée de toute façon je veux
donner j'ai d'autres projets un hockey
des rappeurs comme quoi il n'y en a
quelques-uns de diverses nations aussi
il ya des artisans de partout au canada
il y en a aussi de l'international ou
est-ce qu'il y en aura de plus en plus
des artistes autochtones je sais pas moi
de l'australie ni de nouvelle zélande
d'ailleurs oui mais on louvre à tout le
monde donc oui j'ai déjà quelques férus
compte à quelques artistes qui sont
intéressés dont il voyait avoir bientôt
des artistes l'international c'est pas
le but numéro un
évidemment on essaie aussi de prendre en
utiliser ce l'oreille mais on nie
totalement vains et pourquoi pas donc
on a quand même le réseau qui utilise de
plus en plus aussi à l'international
avec d'autres organismes qui font le
même genre de travail ou ou des artistes
autochtones de différentes cultures à
travers le monde donc oui c'est possible
ça va évoluer je sais que varrault des
nouveaux profils à chaque à chaque mois
puis on nous dit on a des nouvelles
rencontres à chaque année on en a près
d'une cinquantaine donc ça c'est quelque
chose qui évolue quand même rapidement
est ce qu'une plateforme du genre
existent ailleurs au canada
il ya des organismes bien d'autres
plates formes qui font du travail
semblable on peut penser à manitoba
musique qui a lancé apart from au rpm je
crois le clergé moi si je me trompe donc
il ya des des plateformes qui vont
rassembler des réseaux d'artistes dans
des territoires des plateformes de
streaming comme ça j'en connais pas
personnellement dans nos pauvres on ne
fait des recherches évidemment avant de
la partie parce qu'on voulait s'il en
existe et où vous voulez pouvoir
collaborer avec eux puis le développer
oui de façon cohérente comme ça pour le
québec gisèle un nom unique pour
l'instant mais une écoute un peu
d'espoir que je me trompe pas on va
faire une pause musique
on va maintenant se tourner vers charles
et on va parler plutôt de vidéos de
vidéos de femmes donc c'est un événement
vous l'avais dit au début de l'émission
qui a lieu ce soir à 19 heures ce soir
ou au centre d'art clark à montréal à
montréal
c'est à montréal oui donc ceux qui
veulent venir voir l'événement doivent
se rendre à montréal
alors je vous laisse donner le titre de
l'événement oui c'est l'imam lire ou
usines jusqu'aux au projet ces
projections femme autochtone en fait
c'est une soirée qui cherche à faire
découvrir les réalisations d'artistes
femmes au toc de femmes autochtones
cette initiation du collectif des
commissaires autochtone avec en
collaboration avec le standard clark et
catherine boivin qui est la
commissionnaire la commissionnaire la
commissaire la commissaire de
l'événement c'est la dynamique de
wemotaci une artiste multidisciplinaire
et l'a réuni un groupe d'artistes de
jeunes artistes autochtones tous des
femmes et donc
jeannie belles fleurs cash khalkhal
touche catherine boivin elle-même g
jamie et chaque wang d'ubs et tous les
amants et mickey ottawa on a une petite
image que je crois que je sais pas ça a
été envoyée c'est une certaine image de
captures d'écran de son de son vidéo qui
va être projeté ce soir et ses fameux
vaut celle ci oui exactement
donc les yeux verts en fait c'est que ce
soir ils vont nous parler vont nous
proposer des différents visionnement
chaque artiste va aborder un sujet par
rapport à la culture un ange et par
rapport à la culture
chaque artiste présente sa propre façon
vie sa vision des choses en tant que
femme autochtone
donc c'est vraiment aussi pour pouvoir
donner une visibilité à ces jeunes
femmes bloc qui se produisent parfois
ont de la difficulté à à se produire
dans les milieux comme ça et c'est pas
juste des cinéastes des artistes de
toutes disciplines confondues donc on va
aller chercher des votes multiples in ad
personam et guillotin habituellement
c'est une artiste bon c'était dans trop
de café la murale pour exactement
donc là elle l'a fait elle a fait du
film à la fed du document cm je ne sais
pas si m qu'est ce qu'elle a fait j'ai
pas parlé aux artistes en tant que tel
mais ça se mélange entre le documentaire
je vois je vois des noms ici le qui
peuvent qui peuvent qui font des
documents tas qui sont plus d'un niveau
de la performance donc je pense qu'on va
avoir une belle un boom mais aux tympans
de tous ces artistes et là qu'ils vont
présenter 1,6 ces enjeux là c'est parce
que l'idée derrière ça c'est parler de
la réalité des femmes sotoca exactement
exactement parce qu'on sait que la
réalité des femmes autochtones
aujourd'hui avec les avec avec la
commission denquête aussi avec les
femmes assassinées et disparues
la violence faite envers les femmes
autochtones aussi donc c'est en jeu là
aussi je pense qui est qui qui est
criant donc je crois que catherine a
voulu rassembler ces artistes pour
pouvoir donner une voix à ces femmes là
ces jeunes femmes fatiguées réalité qui
existe depuis trop longtemps mais ce
conte
commence à aborder mon en parc de plus
en plus finalement on la mène là sur le
devant de la scène
et ces femmes là se permettre d'en
parler aujourd'hui ce qu'elle n'aurait
peut-être pas fait il ya 20 ou 30 ans
exactement
et puis il va avoir une discussion aussi
qui sera animé par emilie monnaie donc
je vous ai parlé d'elle dernièrement et
aussi comme comme aujourd'hui vous allez
attaquer il aborde aussi par des
bouchers des savoirs autochtones par
chef soit neige
donc si vous voulez découvrir ces jeunes
artistes là et ces femmes là ces femmes
autochtones
c'est ce soir ou au centre d'art de
diffusion clark aux 54 55 rue de gaspé
allait justement vous avez parlé de
nourriture il ya des bouchers si on va
en parler parce que ces coins tonnes qui
les a préparés avec votre conjointe
oui mais c'est sur ces mots fumée qui
vient de signer une baie soit à carleton
sur mer
c'est vraiment bon ça c'est une recette
ancestrale une fille de gaby gaye qui
marie avec ce colloque
donc c'est parce qu'il avait péché se
sont non non non non car pour le tout
puis ça c'est du moose qu'il est gay
c'est du chat du béni oui oui j'ai fait
ça hier soir d'accord commun des chances
au temps des fêtes
et puis je voulais parler de la carte
que vous nous avez apporté une carte
absolument magnifique alors si vous la
regardez de près ce n'est pas une photo
de johnny est vraiment vraiment
incroyable odanak puis ça fait pas
vraiment longtemps café ça aussi puis à
georges parce que tout de suite ou à la
ville allait passer deux ou trois gros
pièce à la louvre apple mouloungui au
musée du jouet il a présentement eoa
maison amérindienne
je pourrais vous faire découvrir
absolument conserver
et puis vous nous avez apporté du thé
faut en parler aussi
c'est fait avec le shaga csat échalotes
ça tu vas trouver sow a sonné boulot oui
cet accord elle chante une force et une
champignons c'est une pas là si ça prend
toutes les bonnes choses du large
oui alors avant de nous quitter
joël germain ça que vous me parliez de
quelques j'imagine qu'ils sont tous
incontournable et 100 125 artistes sur
la plateforme
mais peut-être des noms à retenir à
aller découvrir oui mais l'on peut on
peut naviguer c'est aussi l'idée c'est
qu'ils ont on y trouve que distille
vraiment varié donc c'est sûr qu'il va
voir laura nico et matthew qu'on connaît
peut-être un peu plus au québec dans un
folk rock le macho un artiste y nous
l'aura du québec qui sont plus en plus
populaire il se retrouve là on a ici
quick est une artiste de winnipeg très
connu sur la scène canadienne anglophone
peut-être peut-être moins au québec
non que nous a fait découvrir monclar
qui fait sa chronique musicale à espace
autochtone et elle nous a déjà par des
discours oui on retrouve aussi aux
klaxons ont effectivement je pense à
violence grande par exemple du naskapis
séduit peut donc y voir qu'un mac
donc oui ils font deux époques depuis
longtemps et ils y ont un nouvel album
qui s'en vient c'est excellent très
engagé aussi garner est on vraiment
énormément l'auxiloise on en parlait
encore j'avais quand même un de mes
coups de coeur avec la musique électro
et ses crédos enseignants par exemple
qui va faire du studio de drones
traditionnel des maritimes
mais qui va jouer avec une touche un peu
moderne on entend presque du reggae un
peu environ deux ans fond de musique en
nonne
je prends de nomi à l'infini mais allez
allez découvrir on suggère aussi des
playlists oui on peut monter sa propre
on peut monter sa propre playlist
pendant suggère pour les gens qui ont
juste envie de découvrir dernièrement de
lancer le single live de x heure
justement c'était une collaboration que
le trio montréalais jones s est inscrit
pour notre notre spectacle de l'été
dernier il se retrouve sur la plateforme
c'est une très belle chanson et
harmonieuse lumineuse
un peu un peu divine girel à découvrir
rapidement donc il ya voir ce que ça va
changer
c'est à chaque fois qu'on va aller sur
une plateforme on va pouvoir découvrir
de nouveaux artistes mais également de
nouvelles chansons d'artistes passante
comme kwanten oui c'est ça à chaque fois
qu'on a des nouveaux artistes des
nouvelles on va les mettre on va aller
de l'avant aussi la page d'accueil fait
en sorte qu on met des artistes de
l'avant ce moment on a décidé de mettre
des femmes autochtones de l'avant aussi
justement parce qu'elles sont vraiment
minoritaire dans la plate forme donc on
les met de l'avant dans la page
d'accueil et la playlist proposé par mu
moment mais on n'en fait plus
dépendamment des sorties des activités
des saisons donc ça va changer aussi à
peu près mensuellement l'accord donc une
des manières de découvrir un artiste en
évolution constante je veux dire une
plateforme ainsi en évolution constante
quelqu'un a été surpris en disant hé il
note à chacun ap fontaine sur le site
natacha est une poète mais elle est plus
qu'une poème on avait enregistré du slam
avec natacha on a aussi fait un projet
il ya deux ans en collaboration avec
random recipe hudon qui ont fait on fait
souvent des rencontres d'artistes en
boîte et donc madame le cpie natasha
khan à bellefontaine ont fait une
chanson ensemble qui s'appelle tipiak
qu'on va retrouver on ne fait un bide au
québec wapikoni la chanson et des
musiques nomades donc c'était une pièce
qui a été jouée ici lors de nos
spectacles ya deux ans d'un spectacle
annuel sur la place des festivals
donc c'est une collaboration vraiment
spécial eva eva cela mais il va faire sa
poésie en innu et en français plus
terrain demeure typique est un groupe de
hip hop indie montréal est qui qui
veulent faire le bit autour de ça donc
ça c'est une pièce très forte mais on a
aussi enregistré son slam comme comme un
peu à la manière de nos musées en poésie
donc on peut retrouver son travail sur
la plateforme
il ya aussi un happening qu'on a
découverte cette année c'est très
intéressant il va faire un instinct de
buteur après midi très engagé avec
beaucoup d'humour mais c'est très
contemporain
donc je vous invite à la découvrir
comment on va voir que la musique la
musique autochtone aller loin d'être
traditionnelle n'est ce pas on a dépassé
cette barrière là aujourd'hui la musique
autochtone elle elle va vraiment dans
toutes les directions et elle est
extrêmement moderne
oui ce que j'aime dire si c'est que la
musique traditionnelle est extrêmement
moderne parce que oui c'est encore très
actuel est jeune on a pas mal de jeunes
qui font de la musique traditionnelle et
on auprès de deux groupes de drôme eure
traditionnel ici très actuelle c'est
très moderne et y en a qui vont leur
présence avec une sauce moderne y en a
qui vont faire de façon très
traditionnelle mais c'est pas c'est pas
ces produits vintage c'est pas mal
classés de la musique actuelle ou six
noms traditionnels donc c'est
intéressant de découvrir ça aussi voilà
merci beaucoup merci j'aurais d'éleveurs
nous retrouver vous a fait courir
merci kwanten merci beaucoup bonne
chance pour la suite
merci à nos chroniqueurs encore une fois
aujourd'hui et licha merci beaucoup
bonne semaine la semaine prochaine une
invitation spéciale nous allons recevoir
la ministre québécoise des affaires
autochtones
madame d'amour elle sera là pendant tout
ce facebook live en direct avec nous si
vous avez des questions pour l
profitez-en tout de suite pour commencer
à nous les envoyer nous allons en
préparer nous aussi mais on attend vos
questions que nous allons déposer la
semaine prochaine
merci beaucoup la semaine prochaine et
là nous on peut manger pendant ce temps
là
[Rires]
we do wah
[Musique]